Oh might be working it's working okay
the first one didn't work the second one
did didn't it okay now what mm okay
I'd have six names Oh Indian it's tried
the Benko gambit maybe not really my
style but let's give it a whirl d 5b 5
chop a 6
ah ok no chopping well what do we have
here
I could this can transpose into a pan
off Botvinnik attack takes takes d5 and
that's the situation we're in so okay
let's run with this d5 before it's too
late get it in now okay well I'm gonna
go with this it's a quiet approach and
I'm not going to take on this square
until the bishop moves I think right now
is a good time it's Castle and I'm not
so sure how purposeful that advance is
now my only question is knight c6 b for
d5 or do I play b6 Bishop b7 first I
like this move right away so let's do it
maybe I could think about Bishop a6 as
well so notice how I'm retaining some
options at least if I were to play
knight c6 forget about playing Bishop a6
that's dropping stuff of course
so maybe Bishop b7 or a six of these two
bishops this is the more important one
to get rid of reason for that it's the
guy that can control this blockade
Square and this is the square I want to
focus on
the most d5 controlled d5 and you
control the game or do you I'm really
considering this I think I like it so
I'm gonna do it
I could be assured now that the
LightSquared bishop s' will be out of
here get out of here light square bishop
I think this actually helps me I think
it would be a bit more uncomfortable for
me if the Queen were to have played to
e2 or b3 something just supporting the
bishop now I think things are squeaky
clean I have a strong control over d5
there were a couple different ways I
could have gotten to that Square seems
like a good enough one doesn't allow
wipe the possibility of taking this
knight now is night right here gonna be
a bother
I'm not so sure about that I mean I
might be okay with give allowing for a
knight c6 move picking up my dark square
bishop or like that's just picking up my
bishops and so I only have one no follow
up moves okay well now I'm not having to
worry at all about this guy am i all
right let's go pressure on the night the
more trades are going to favor what side
let's let my queen play more trades will
favor the side playing against the
isolated Queen Pond there's a dynamic
advantage or there's the potential for
dynamics on the white side with this
pond pushing forward at the right moment
changing the pond structure and then
maybe catching black a bit off-balance
but as the position simplifies we're
getting into a technical position or in
this case what the endgame so
is it okay to just trade Queens am i
okay with allowing this rook to have
this a file yes it doubles the be pawns
but is that a liability is it really I
guess I'll go for it and as a follow-up
play here I think it's important to
maybe run with that well I guess I still
could have played Knight d5 but I was
concerned about rook a six and then
doubling up but in response to that rook
a six move I could have well let's say
Knight B 4 okay right here just in the
nick of time do not let this pig and get
on the seventh no pigs and let's go King
you know you want to play I don't want
to trade let's go King defend that pawn
get towards the center out of twenty
second lead time wise for white I think
I want to keep one pair of rooks on the
board oh I missed that move oh no no no
no don't say it isn't so
okay let's do this I have to kick it
into a high gear
why did I allow that I should just threw
my Brook here there's no good defense to
it fortunately my knight is a tough guy
let's go rooks get active because you're
down upon team Black is struggling right
now Oh fortunately I have still very
active pieces in this Knight
it's still a bit ways off from doing any
damage then you hack you to go after
this little guy right here the beep on
let's go beep on my knight is there to
defend my bishop
so now what and my night can't be
attacked so easily can it oh okay what
do you do here
one Pig on the second no just take the
rook oh this is not good
this is how it started last oh wait a
second wait a second wait a second grab
this bishop that was a free rook two two
videos ago that I posted on YouTube I
said I had a free queen I was like take
free Queens now it's take free rooks
anything that's free take it just take
it right away
oh okay I could take this bishop but the
rook grabs this guy but how about I say
hey let's go you got to move the bishop
where are you gonna move I get the beep
on blockade you see one one way to view
this is that I even though I'm down upon
its this pun is a bit non-existent it's
a passed pawn but it's blockaded right
I'm okay I'm not Wow okay let's do this
let's grab the rope the real caster
recapture now there we go
finally out of pawn back and this guy is
uh he's gonna be running fast isn't he
this bishop has a tough time doing stuff
doesn't it or does it
um let's push this guy he's passed my
king is close to well let's get rid of
this Knight you know they're night good
vs good night versus bad bishop
situation maybe
ooh okay let's do this I'm gonna have to
calculate a little bit tags takes pawn
push King up up up I don't know if
that's a win how about I do this or not
how about I move fast
okay can I get I'm gonna get this pawn
now getting this pound 18 seconds my
opponent is going click can I just get
this pawn what's the time situation
it's quit checking me what'd I do to
deserve this
quit your check-in man quit checking me
man
run pond you know you want to run I'll
just take the night it was a freebie
more free pieces are they shouldn't have
taken my night they're in trouble now
that's a mating one - oh that one stings
free pieces everywhere this is not gonna
look well come tournament time do not be
listening with your headphones good game
oh man don't make it too simple when it
comes down to me being a low on time
keep it complicated or actually no
nevermind don't do that it's good advice
anyhow could lose so many more games if
that was just followed keep the
complicated don't trade so much it's
easier to pre move when there's few
pieces on the board okay anyhow let's
back up here and see what there is to
take away from it this move I think you
could save yourself that move I don't
know if the pin is that annoying there's
there's way out there's ways out of it
there's a line that runs right into a
simplified endgame the Queen's coming
off black being on castled Queen coming
out to b3
a take on b7 something like an
in-between check on cease c6 and then
grab on b5 if you're not familiar with
the variation this really just is
probably a bunch of gibberish that I'm
throwing out there to you but anyhow
that you could do without this h3 move
is what I'm getting at there's it turns
out to be a waste I think and maybe
well I guess it's I'm I'll end up cast
like if you don't declare this bishops
intentions if you don't move it just yet
you play Knight c3 I Castle and then
okay eventually when he plays I take and
we're kind of in the same territory um
here's an interesting thing
instead of castle when you if you play
Knight c3 you give me a bit more to chew
on because notice this if your night is
on c3 and I'm playing b6 I think you
have an opportunity to play d5 and this
might this diagonal since it's opened
might become a problem so at least
consider the differences that could come
about between you know Castle and Knight
c3 this might turn out to give me a bit
more to think about
b6 Bishop d7 idea huh might be something
off with that and right here I think
Queen e2 is a bit better I think you
kind of helped my Knights out I'm really
comfortable in this position I have
control over that
we're exchanging more and more and I
really shouldn't have given up that pun
and I don't know that I should have been
playing a5 just how I was giving a quick
suggestion earlier about h3 do without
that I think I should take my advice
with regard to me pushing a5 in this
instance not so sure about that probably
just night here centralize the knight
then play f6 King here hopefully don't
drop a pawn again
don't drop that e pawn but just probably
unnecessary
I forgot that if Knight d5 and you were
to plant you rock on 86 I could always
play Knight b4 and kick him away and
then follow up with the a5 if I really
needed to get him out of there so
I think maybe consider the knight c3
move instead of castle right here and
also do without h3 those are just a
couple quick points